So how do you folks,
thank you guys for coming.
Uh,
my name is Scott Maxwell.
I'm a Googler.
Um,
and our guest speaker today is Digo Porque Harris.
He is the president and Cto of a company named ds maker.
Um,
in 2012,
uh,
he,
hosted a Kickstarter for,
uh,
building a three d printer.
The buco bought named cleverly after his dog,
um,
and it was so successful at raised almost four times the expected funds and that
helped Diego to go on and,
uh,
fund,
other three d printers,
including this one right here.
This is my personal printer,
uh,
the Bukito printer.
And over the course of Diego's talk,
you're going to see it make one of these.
Um,
uh,
so Diego is here to talk to us today about the,
make a revolution and,
uh,
designing and building a three d printer and where they make a revolution coast
from here.
Would you join me please?
And welcoming Diego.
Precarious.
Okay,
cool.
Hi Guys.
How are you guys doing?
Um,
like I said,
I'm Diego.
Um,
I started these maker.
Uh,
we kinda have the first a three d printer store in the country that we opened in
Pasadena in 2012.
And uh,
yeah,
once we did the,
I did the Kickstarter,
that's when I opened the store and the ball started rolling from there.
Um,
and uh,
he invited me.
Thank you Scott for inviting me.
Um,
he invited me to show you guys a little the process and what the three d printer
is made out of kind of the components and um,
how I kinda got to design a three d printer I guess.
And um,
and you know the details from there.
So,
um,
well I was going to do today is kind of just go over the components of the three
d printer,
kind of what they do,
what's kind of important about him and how they function.
Um,
and then go into a little bit of the software stuff.
Any software people here.
I figured.
So we'll try to jump into the software a little bit and then we could open it up
for like Qa cause um,
um,
I'll give you a kind of a crash course of,
you know,
how three d printer works.
But then I'd like to know what you guys want to know that I can answer more
specific thing.
Sounds good.
Great.
Um,
all right.
So let's just jump right in there.
Um,
how to build an FDM printer.
first of all,
there's many technologies,
um,
in three d printing.
It's not just this type.
There's powder systems,
there's liquid resin systems,
there's a paper one,
the one that uses paper,
there's a bunch of technologies.
Um,
I focused on this one because it was a very accessible type of three d printing.
it's very affordable.
It's easy to get parts.
It's not messy.
There's no powder liquids or anything crazy to deal with.
So it's really easy.
It's very good home based type of machine or even an office,
um,
as it,
cause he's Scott just like carries it everywhere with him.
So very practical machine.
So that's why I really liked it.
And it became my ultimate tool to just create stuff.
Um,
how many of you guys,
uh,
made a three d prints or worked with three d printers so far?
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
Um,
yeah,
so when I started in 2012,
I'd asked that question and people were like,
what is three d printing?
What are you talking about?
Uh,
finally it's great that technology of ketchup and it's very a very out there,
a lot of competition too.
So just start off,
there's basically five components to a three d printer.
Um,
you got the Gantry and the frame.
Sometimes they're there together.
Uh,
but the country gantry is what makes everything move in three d space.
Um,
the extruder is what kind of spits out the material basically.
this type of three d printer is,
uh,
if you simplify,
it's basically a hot glue gun,
a very fancy hog Logan.
It just melts material and pours it into layer by layer.
And when we get to the software part of things,
you'll see how that happens a little more detail.
Um,
and then you have the platform,
uh,
which is,
where your object starts from.
Um,
it can kind of start in outer space,
so it has to start somewhere.
So in this case,
the platform is where everything grows from.
Um,
and to make all that happen,
you have all the electronics that holds it together.
Um,
it makes the motor's move,
that temperatures remained steady,
it reads in the data,
all that stuff.
That's the electronics part.
And then the filament.
Uh,
finally the film is what creates your object and what you know eventually
becomes the object that you,
that the machine outfits,
right.
So let's jump in there.
So first you have the gantry and something about what's cool about three d space
is there's many ways to deal with three d space in a mechanical way.
Um,
so if you're trying to make a three d printer,
you kind of have to decide,
decide the pros and cons of what kind of gantry system you want for what kind of
advantages,
uh,
that you want to create for the machine that you want to create a cause.
They all have their little pros and cons and there's a few more details about
all these.
Uh,
I'm going to talk over,
uh,
talk about,
um,
but I'm going to give you kind of the basics of what each gantry system,
how it helps or maybe it's not so good and vice versa.
So,
um,
first of all,
there's a pretty much three basic sets of how to move in three d space.
You have,
you have three spaces,
x,
Y,
and Z,
right?
So you need a,
usually you move and two of those dimensions and then the,
uh,
constantly basically as,
as a full layer,
a two dimensional layer.
And then the Z is usually the one that makes it into the three d part.
So your regular paper printer is a tutee machine,
right?
So it's x and y machine,
but what makes a three d printer three d printer is that it moves up into the z
axis and creates another layer on top of that one.
Um,
so there's three different ways to kind of do that.
and a three d printer.
Basically you can move the x and y move them in your x and y direction and then
the z moves in a certain way or you could move,
uh,
or you can move the,
the extruder,
which is dispensing the material that could just stay steady and you can move
the platform in x and y.
Or you could do a combination of those were the extruder just moves into x and
then moves up also.
But the platform is a why like this one.
And we'll go over those quick examples.
So for instance,
um,
if you've ever seen the machines like this,
they're kind of more boxy and stuff.
They usually work in the x and y as the extruder and then the z and the
platform.
So the,
the head basically moves like a,
like a plotter.
If you guys ever done a like drafting with blueprints and stuff that,
or you're like [inaudible],
uh,
that's the way of doing it.
Um,
you move in two directions,
uh,
for the extruder and then the z platform would move down or are,
or you can move everything up.
That whole gantry up.
Um,
so the,
the,
this is one of the probably the best ways to make a three d printer.
It has the most advantages I think,
um,
as far as,
uh,
you know,
getting a really good output of your prints,
uh,
with a lot less,
effort.
Um,
so basically,
uh,
just moving the head means that you have,
you know,
how heavy that head is all the time and it never changes the weight.
So if you'd find tune your printer,
you could figure out the accelerations and the jerkiness that it could take and
all that.
And it's kind of static.
It doesn't change over time.
Um,
so that way it will be very consistent prints and you could build as big as you
want and you'll stay very consistent.
Um,
the cons about this is that,
uh,
when a major cons is that it does make the system a little complex.
Um,
there's,
you have two axes running in like in parallel and motors are going to be in the
same area and things like that.
Um,
so that's one thing and sometimes people,
uh,
the way it's designed is since the,
if the head is very heavy,
it gets even more complicated to make all the belts really tight and the motor
stronger and all that.
So instead what they do is they put the extruder or somewhere else and they feed
into it.
And I'm going to explain about that in a little bit and that kind of compromises
a little bit of the extrusion feature or details,
but,
um,
it just makes things a little more complicated.
So
you'll see it gets things a worked up in a little different way.
Um,
the next way to do it is moving your platform x and y and then just lifting the
head up.
Like in this case where the,
the head just stays in one spot as the layer prints and then the head just moves
a little bit.
But the platform keeps going.
Um,
this does make the,
in in this format,
it makes the three d printer a little bit,
maybe cheaper and a little maybe easier.
Uh,
but the drawbacks is that moving the three d printed object that's being
printed,
so throughout your print,
the,
the nurses and the weights start shifting or it starts getting heavier and
heavier and you can't really compensate for that in a really good way.
So you'd have to just make everything nice and solid to begin with,
which means you have a little heavier motors are heavier stuff to deal with.
Um,
and also it's probably the one of the least efficient use of space,
um,
because the platform has,
the whole platform has to move from one end to the other.
So you need those margins,
uh,
to deal with that.
Right.
Um,
and the other case,
like the other machine,
the only margin you have to deal with is the head itself.
And if the head's pretty small,
then there's not a lot of extra footprints compared to how big your printer
prints.
All right.
And then the other form is like the ones I make.
Um,
like the Bukito.
And the way,
the reason we made this one is that,
um,
we decided that making the,
the axis very independent to each other,
we'll make them very robust.
Um,
but it does it so it keeps the machine very simple.
So the y has its own rail and its own direction,
its own motor and that's it.
With the platform,
the x moves the head back and forth and then we created a system to move the x
or yeah,
the extruder up.
Um,
and I decided to do this because it was a,
um,
in this way I actually created the rails to be also the frame.
So it became very,
very simplified machine.
Um,
and it's very,
very robust.
And one of the features that we like bragging about it on this machine is that
it could print like in naming any direction,
um,
cause everything's very stiff in light and uh,
uh,
you know,
very sturdy type of machine.
Um,
the disadvantage about this is that you're kind of moving the platform.
The thing is we're not moving it in two dimensions.
We're only moving in one.
So it's a little,
it's just a little easier to deal with.
And there's a lot less issues compared to moving in the x and y direction,
right?
No.
So,
oh yeah.
So this is a picture of my,
the Buco about,
uh,
my,
the first Michigan,
the predecessor to this one.
And,
um,
and I talk about a little funny thing that I discovered in designing this
machine,
um,
and researching why other people did certain things.
Um,
in this case we did the same system is this,
um,
but we had the,
uh,
you could see the extruder in the middle and then the whole,
the whole z movement and the z space moves up a parallel to each other.
So we have two,
two motors and screws to lift all that up right to z.
Uh,
that makes it a little more complex,
but,
um,
it does make it actually practical.
And the first question is we've had,
when we would,
you know,
show people the machine is,
they're like,
well,
why do you have two motors,
uh,
with two screws on each side?
I want you to just use one motor and time together with the bell and do it that,
right?
So they're always in sync.
So,
um,
if one gets a little,
it won't,
you know,
one won't go higher than the other by itself.
Um,
the reason is we actually investigated it and we ended up finding out that I'm
using two motors independently,
but tied together like chronically was pretty much the same reliability as doing
the belt system,
but it actually costs less to do it.
Um,
and you actually get double,
almost double the power because we have two motors lifting it up.
So even if you have two small motors,
they're both doing half the weight.
Um,
and doing the belt system,
you have to have the perfect size belt because it has to be continuous belt.
So the tightness has to be there,
you have to make the bearings and the pulleys and all that and ended up actually
costing more to do that and just putting two independent motors wired together.
So that was like one of the cool like early discoveries and I'm like,
oh,
that's why they do that.
So it was very interesting to find stuff like that out.
Um,
all right.
so another gantry system that exists,
there's a few,
a couple of other ones.
Um,
it's called a delta machine.
I don't know if you guys seen these types of three d printers.
Um,
basically they use three motors and three arms to do all x,
Y,
and z axes.
Um,
and the pros about this is that you have three exact arms and three exact motors
through exact belts,
through exact everything to do all your,
uh,
x,
Y and z movements.
Um,
the cons is that you probably guys like that word Algorithms,
um,
this type of machine compared to these,
these are very linear,
very,
uh,
static resolution.
So if it moves,
you know,
one millimeter here,
it takes certain amount of steps.
And if it moves it over here,
it takes the exact same amount of steps to move that one millimeter no matter
where it's at.
It's very consistent,
very,
you know,
one or it's like a ruler.
Um,
these machines working arcs.
So every art changes,
constant resolution.
There's never a spot where the resolution is the same throughout the platform.
And to make that happen,
it takes some pretty serious algorithm in math and a lot of decimal points.
Um,
and some of these microcontrollers can't handle that many precision decimal
points sometimes.
So if you get machines like this,
you probably want the best,
uh,
chip possible to run it because you have a lot of resumes,
a lot of resolution and math to deal with.
Um,
and the other thing is if something,
it's a little harder to get these really straight because if something's a
little off,
um,
it might still work fine,
but it's not going to be very accurate because one little thing somewhere is
going to be really hard to catch or figure out where it's not straight.
And,
uh,
and since you're kind of moving the extruder,
um,
in every direction,
you kind of need the extruder to be pretty light.
Um,
you can't put like a,
it's not,
you can't,
it's a,
once you put a heavy motor on there,
then you have a lot of inertia is going back and forth and uh,
that's just,
that starts affecting your resolution,
your reliability.
Like if it travels too far and it jerks too much,
the steps a on a motor might change and then it's completely out of whack really
fast.
So,
so it's very sensitive.
Yeah.
And your speed goes down.
So as your weight goes up,
your speed starts going way down really fast.
Cool.
And then the other one that's kind of out there that I saw,
it's kind of weird.
It was also,
it's called a polar machine.
There was only a few out there because it's not really an advantageous way of
doing it,
but in this way,
the head kind of,
uh,
actually moves in the x kind of direction and the z direction like ours,
but the plate moves in a circle and that must be even more serious algorithms to
figure that out.
Um,
and so I think it's like fun machine to watch,
shall I brands.
But when you actually print stuff on it,
you'll see,
I don't know if he could tell him this and,
but it creates like really weird like patterns in your object just because it's
probably,
it's a lot of it to do with the rounding of decimal points and the algorithms
like you,
you can't do,
it's just really hard and these processors can't do that.
Be Huge of a calculations for that.
So that's another way of,
uh,
doing the x,
Y and z movement.
All right.
Um,
the other one,
the other newer ones that I saw come up because of three d printing that are
here is called core x,
y or h bots.
And this one's getting very popular because it has a lot of good advantages.
Um,
it's a little more complex to design.
You have to really do some good serious,
uh,
precision where all the stuff goes.
But once you have it,
it's a very,
very solid a type of working.
And the way it works is you just have two motors in the back,
uh,
or in the front.
It depends how you design it and it works.
Kind of like an etch a sketch.
Have you got,
you guys do decks,
etch a sketch at some point,
right?
So it's just kind of moving two knobs and depending on the sequence of how you
move them together,
it goes in different directions.
Um,
so if you move just 1:00 AM I go diagonal one way,
if you move the other goes the other way and vice versa.
And that's how they h the kind of h.
Dot.
Works.
Um,
the good about this is it,
it gets very efficient to make that compared to the other,
just a normal x and y with a bunch of belts in rods.
Um,
this one has a lot less component count to do it.
but you need a few components that need to be very nice and solid,
like the rails and things.
Um,
this one's very good for mass production.
Yeah.
So this is an Hba and they'll,
uh,
the way this works is a one,
one is attached to one side and one's attached to the other side of the
carriage.
Um,
and depends on the sequence,
how they move.
It makes all your x and y movements.
Um,
on the core x,
y this is the core x,
y system.
And if you guys like math problems and equations or some down there,
uh,
but it's actually very simple.
And,
uh,
the way it works is when you spin one motor actually goes diagonal and when you
spend the other one,
it goes the other direction.
So when they both been together,
it goes in the x or the y direction.
Um,
it depends on which rotation they do.
and I have a machine that we offer now that actually uses a system and it's
really nice.
Um,
and it's very calm.
It's very compact.
The way they do it.
And the advantage over core x,
y,
which is this one over this one,
is that the core x,
y um ha is naturally self aligning.
It's,
Oh,
it always wants to kind of keep itself parallel to each one because it has the
exact same forces pulling on itself every time it moves the age.
But um,
unfortunately when you have one,
maybe one rail is dragging a little bit,
it's going to want to bind and get crooked pretty easily.
So the,
the adoption of the core x y is a lot better because it's kind of like a self
aligning.
You don't have to go and double check that things are straight.
Again,
if something gets out of whack,
it kind of self does it on its own.
So that's something really cool about the core x y system,
Huh?
No.
Um,
not that I know of,
especially cause a lot of manufacturers are using it is so,
uh,
if there is,
nobody has called it out anywhere,
but I think somebody posted this a long time ago.
Maybe Leonardo dementia,
I don't know.
It could be way back then.
Uh,
but it came out and it got published and they talked about it.
It's probably some university or something.
Um,
yeah.
And,
and people adopted it.
Um,
I kinda so I,
I believe it's open source.
You can totally do that.
Exactly.
Um,
yeah.
It's super possible that it could be.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Old,
uh,
old drafting boards that had the rulers that moved in parallel,
they would use stuff like that,
uh,
that would help you move him,
you know,
so that you don't have to just sit there and hold everything.
It would just kind of keep itself straight.
They had stuff like that going on with that.
Um,
and plotters,
I think some plotters did things like that too.
Um,
but this is a machine we offer.
Uh,
it's actually made in Germany.
It's called the craft bop,
but this one uses the core x,
y.
And it was a good chance for me to actually see somebody created.
And I've have,
uh,
more than thousand hours on this machine and it works really nice.
Super steady.
Never gets out of whack.
Very,
very well belt.
Cool.
All right.
So now we get to the extruder.
Um,
so like I explained before,
this is a kind of a very fancy hot glue gun and it's pretty simple.
The way it works.
Um,
extraordinary basically consist,
it starts off at the top where the material comes in and has usually we have a
gear,
uh,
some kind of gear,
type of wheel with teeth on it.
And that kind of forcefully just bites into the material and feeds it through.
And you'll,
you always have the wheel on the other side to just put the pressure on it.
Um,
there's some extruders there.
There's like another 20 ways to make an extruder,
but this is the most common,
uh,
cause you could have teeth on both sides if you want and things like that,
but it gets more complicated.
And then from there it goes down,
usually a barrel,
which has to be cold.
And then right at the tip is where your heater and a sensor is to heat up the
material at the right temperature for what you're working with.
Um,
and that comes out of the a lot smaller hole.
MMM.
So that's basically how an extruder works.
Does that make sense?
Everybody?
What's the
what?
Oh,
well whoever illustrated this called it thin plastic.
But technically it might be because the motor,
the motor pulses very gently,
uh,
but it's so small it doesn't come out.
It'd be,
it's comes out like a noodle.
So it just comes out in one stream usually.
Um,
all right,
so the main part of the extruder is kind of this one.
Um,
it's not the most important because they all have to kind of work together.
A Three d printer is one of those machines that if one part doesn't work right
or not,
nothing really good comes out of like everything has to work in unison and,
uh,
an orchestration for it to work.
Right.
Um,
but this is kind of like a,
what a hot end looks like.
And I think I brought one here somewhere.
Uh,
Jonathan.
Oh,
do you have the box with the little extruder samples and stuff?
Yeah.
Could you go,
well,
we're bringing us home.
I'll,
I'll bring some stuff to pass around so you guys can look at it up close.
Um,
but the,
this is a typical design of an extruder,
which has a,
a heater cartridge through the whole,
um,
and then the main barrel.
And then the nozzle tip and the nozzle is what creates the resolution of your
printer.
So if it's a 0.4 millimeter,
a nozzle,
that means your,
your beads going to be at least 0.4 millimeters.
Um,
it can't be skinnier,
so it has to at least come out and it's like,
uh,
pushing to space,
toothpaste out of it.
Uh,
uh,
tube,
it only comes out that thick.
It won't come out skinnier than that.
Um,
so you can't get resolution sharper than that.
so if you want a higher resolution,
you've got to get a smaller hole for your nozzle.
Um,
but the important part about this is that,
um,
the smaller the hole and the bigger the filament,
the more back pressure there is,
which means a motor that's driving the filament down into it and needs to be a
lot stronger,
uh,
when the ratio is really a big.
Um,
so in this case,
uh,
the one 75 millimeter thick filaments that you'll see mentioned later also,
um,
is getting a lot more popular because your back pressure is so much less
compared.
So if I have a,
uh,
a thicker filament that's like three millimeter,
which is the other common size compared to a 0.5 millimeter nozzle and a one 75
millimeter.
And also with a 0.5 millimeter nozzle with the same amount,
the back pressures like six times different actually because it's a volume based
type of calculation.
Um,
so there's an advantage and disadvantage of the two,
but the one 75 is getting more popular because it's an easier way to drive that
filament through the nozzle.
Um,
and so you need a lot less hardware and ends up being a little more reliable and
things like that.
Um,
so yeah,
so the heater block has a cartridge and then a sensor and right next to it to
kind of,
so the process or could figure out what,
uh,
what the temperature is going on with it.
Um,
the other really important part about this is that since you have this really
hot thing going on,
at the tip of that,
heat's going to travel up throughout the extruder all the way up as things,
as time goes by,
obviously.
Um,
so most of these extruders,
um,
like this one has a fan in the front and that keeps that top part fighting the
cold back down into that heating area.
Um,
and the reason is that,
um,
that if the filament starts melting too early,
it's going to create a lots of friction and trying to go down that tube and it,
and plastic expands too.
So it's gonna like try to shove it's way down.
So,
uh,
the basic rule about three d printing with this type is you want like the
smallest transition between the cold and the hot.
So that way as soon as it gets warm,
it just melts and it's,
and it's there and you create the least amount of friction.
Um,
I got pass a couple of these arena.
You guys want chicken mountain?
Um,
sort of here.
This is a Bukito extruder.
Um,
I guess could look at,
and you guys know you probably took it apart,
yours,
uh,
and this is from another company also,
you guys could train and this is a whole extruder mechanism so he could see that
that heat sinks there.
Um,
everything.
So it's important to kind of keep that top part,
uh,
that top part nice and cold.
And sometimes I get tech support calls and they're like,
Hey,
my film and keeps jamming.
What's going on in this?
And one of the first thing I started asking is,
is that fan on that top working?
They're like,
no.
So that usually means that it gets so much so hot up there that things are just
getting stuck a way sooner and then the motor just can't handle it.
Um,
and then the,
the next part up is the drive gear.
Uh,
the drive,
we call it the drive gear because it's kind of a gear and that kind of drives
the filament down into it.
Um,
this is like an old fashioned one.
I got a pass to one of these around.
You guys want to see it.
Um,
this was like the really homemade three d printed version of an extruder,
um,
around,
and that's,
uh,
one of my first prototypes.
Use this because that was the easiest way.
You could three d print a motor with a big gear and it created a lot more
leverage and you can drive everything that way.
Um,
now there are a lot more compact,
um,
like this one,
later if you guys want to come up and look at it,
it has a drive gear here and you can see what's going on and how it works and
everything.
Um,
but as you could see there,
it's pretty simple.
It's the motor has the main gear part with the teeth and then there's an idler
pulley that pushes that filament against it,
uh,
with some good pressure from that spring.
And so that way it's a,
you know,
it has a good grip on it.
And these drive gears,
the golden ones that you see there,
uh,
they're actually brass,
but uh,
those are the ones we manufacturer for this printer.
And I specifically went to a manufacturer that makes gears and we,
and I worked with them and we made these drive gears that are really sharp and
digging really good.
And we created like one of the most reliable drive gears,
um,
out there for three d printers.
All right.
Um,
and now there's two different ways to extrude dysplastic.
There's kind of like a,
a remote way of doing it and then a direct way to do it.
And the remote way is called a bone and extruder and the direct way is just
called direct drive.
Um,
the Bukito works in a boat and uh,
extruder way.
And the advantage of that is that you could put a nice heavy motor,
um,
or heavier,
more complicated stuff.
I'm away from the,
from the actual hot end itself,
so,
so you could keep your head or your extruder or very light and having the
extruder lay it makes,
makes things move faster and you could do a lot of,
uh,
better mechanical stuff for that.
Um,
the disadvantage of that is that you have,
uh,
a history sis,
which means like a little delay.
You have a little bit of a delay every time the,
the,
the extruder motor pushes the filament,
there's a little compression trickle compression going on and then it comes out.
Um,
so in software you have to deal with the little bit more fine tuning of,
oh,
it should start extruding right before it needs to extrude and then retract a
little before it needs to retract this.
There's a little delay between the extrusion here and there.
Um,
but the Dura and the other disadvantage is that you can't,
uh,
you can't run a flexible filaments,
through or not flexible.
Uh,
very elastic filaments.
There's some filaments that are very rubbery and if you try to push him through
a tube,
they're just going to kind of create a lot of friction and expand and bunch up
and just get stuck there and it just won't come out to the other end.
Um,
so a direct drive means the extruders right next to the nozzle.
kind of like the one you're passing on this side.
Like the,
the drive systems goes right down into the barrel.
And that's the,
the advantage of that is that you could print very flexible filaments cause
there's really not a lot where it could go or bunch up.
It's just going right straight down that hot end.
All right.
Um,
cool.
and then there's machines that have multi extruders.
Uh,
when we started I created a dual extruder machine and found out a lot of
technical,
uh,
technical issues with doing that.
It's very difficult.
Um,
but now they're coming up with different ways of doing it.
the,
the more brute force way of doing it is the like the top one.
It's a,
there's just four nozzles there and you have for the extruder motors driving the
and extruding and you have software dealing with which one should extreme,
uh,
first.
Um,
the disadvantage about that is that every nozzle and this type of setup has to
be exactly in the exact same height.
So if one's tightened a little harder and the other one's going to be higher or
lower than the other,
and that means if one's printing another of those nozzles might knock over what
you're trying to print or vice versa.
When the other one prints,
the other one's going to knock over the other one.
And that was a very big challenge.
So people start coming up with the ones like the other one,
which is like one nozzle and they feed three filaments through it.
Um,
the disadvantage about that is that now you can't do different materials,
uh,
mostly because you only have one heat source and they all have to be the same
time.
Sure,
sure.
Um,
and then,
uh,
there's other methods of doing it.
This one is pretty new and it's getting popular,
but he basically got one extruder and then a fee all lines feeding into that one
also.
But he created this little board that you can adapt to your current printer and
it just gets a signal and it figures out how to retract one and then feed the
other one into it.
And it could actually change temperatures every time it does that.
Um,
because only one film it's going through at a time,
but it has a very clever switching mechanism,
like for a more software combination to do to that.
All right.
Uh,
and then another little important thing about a extruders is that there are some
materials like pla that you're using.
If you notice here,
there's another little fan on,
on the machine here that some materials like to be cooled down as soon as they
come out of the nozzle.
Um,
and the reason for pla is that when you cool down,
it becomes very hard and stiff immediately.
So the next layer could go on it very smoothly and evenly and they won't,
they won't affect each other.
Some other materials like abs plastic,
which is like Lego plastic,
um,
they,
they need to be kept warm.
Actually,
it's complete opposite.
They need to be kept warm and hot.
Um,
if not,
the layer on the bottom shrinks so much that the next layer up shrinks a little
bit and it starts curling up all the bottom layers under that.
And it creates a really bad chain reaction,
um,
during your print.
Um,
and then so the other part of the three printers,
your platform,
that's where everything starts.
Um,
and this is,
uh,
this is the tricky part.
It depends on what you're trying to print.
A lot of materials have different surfaces that it likes to work on.
Um,
the most common one is to use a heated platform,
uh,
which is just like a hot plate,
but it's
uh,
and it's made specifically to get pretty hot for abs plastic.
I'll pass this around.
These are some materials,
um,
for abs plastic you need to keep it very warm.
So this is like one of the hot plates that we use.
Um,
and it likes to stick on a capped on tape might take,
which is like this one.
MMM.
So those kind of go together.
And then,
uh,
there's nylon,
nylon and uh,
other materials like PETG that like other materials,
this is a nylon plate for nylon to stick on.
And actually I didn't peel this away,
but uh,
this is another material that we're starting to use now that's very,
it's very high tech and it seems to stick to a lot more materials than just one
or the other.
No.
Um,
so this is kind of an example of some thing,
some things that are out there to,
to do different,
uh,
different materials for them to add heat to the platform.
Um,
the black one is like a commercially available.
It's actually I think a polycarbonate and no one likes to stick to pla and abs
when it's really hot.
I'm the blue tape is what we use for three d with printers for pla that don't
have a heated platform.
Um,
the blue tape is actually the normal three m scotch tape they use for masking
when you paint.
Um,
for summary,
somebody found out that was the best type of tape that bla likes to stick to.
Um,
the funny thing is only the three m scotch brand seems to work the best.
Uh,
people have tried other formulas,
other brands and stuff and it just doesn't work as nice.
Um,
and at one point I met a guy that works at three m,
uh,
at like a networking thing and uh,
I asked him like,
Hey,
what do you guys do with the,
was a tape that it seems to work for this pla.
He's like,
well,
we have really proprietary chemicals to make that happen and we're not gonna
tell you what they are.
So,
um,
the thing you think,
oh,
well,
why would the surface of the,
the blue tape works so well?
And what it is is that they actually have a special surface for that.
So the adhesive of the tape on going on top of it in the role,
um,
comes off of it without,
without sticking to that surface,
you know,
it has that perfect the type of adhesion where it just works.
So you could roll it off the role without it ripping apart or the adhesive going
on the wrong side.
Um,
and then there's Polyman,
uh,
polyimide tape,
which is the yellow stuff,
which I know JPL people see this all over the place.
It's a very high temperature conductive tape that they use for electronics for
things.
If you see things covered in like gold tape,
it's usually this stuff.
It's called a capstone or polyimide tape.
And abs likes to,
to that really well when it's heated.
Um,
and then there's some materials like nylon,
uh,
which we could pass around leader.
But a nylon likes porous materials.
So unfortunately if you have a printer with Cap Dante,
if you can't really print nylon on it,
cause nylon doesn't like to stick to shiny stuff,
it likes poorest stuff.
So some people just go and get really cheap wood on it or,
or that other material that's called a linen phenolic that has a very micro pore
in it and nylon likes to stick to it.
Um,
so every,
every material likes its surface for some reason.
Um,
and then the other important really part of a platform is how flat it is.
I've always had people come up to us and they go,
oh that's a cool printer,
but could you make a really big one?
And I'm like,
yeah,
that's fine,
but where are you going to get a flat piece of metal at the tolerances you want
to be that big.
Um,
and the only really good way to do that is to get one machine and that gets
really expensive fast.
Um,
so most pieces of metal that you get from the stock,
you know,
after about 10 inches,
they just start their tolerances.
Just go off out the door when you're trying to print,
you know,
300 micron layers from one end to the other.
It could be completely warped everywhere and you almost can't even look at it.
And then some people go,
well,
why don't you put a big piece of glass on it?
Well,
have you ever measured glass?
It's never perfect.
Each site is a little thinner and thicker than other places.
So,
um,
there's those challenges that you run into when you design a printer.
Um,
there's a,
there's these new methods coming out and getting more sophisticated where
there's doubt printers that actually go in through and since your whole board
with a sensor with like a metal detector basically,
and it creates,
it's curviness and it compensates all your three d printing for it.
Um,
like that orange machine with all the extruders.
The guy that,
uh,
designed that one,
his name's pressure,
uh,
Joseph pressure and he,
he created a heated bed with special targets on it that he could run your
software,
even if your printers like totally crooked,
it'll go and find those dots and it'll create an,
the algorithm.
And the compensation to just print your object straight as possible.
Even no matter how quick you do your machine is,
it's pretty neat.
Um,
but those are the challenges that you run into and creating a three d printer.
and then the,
uh,
the next major component,
it was electronics.
Um,
and what the electronics basically do an a three d printer,
um,
at Ge moved it was in third,
earlier should have been on the next line.
But,
uh,
the electronics in this case out of the lower cost machines,
they basically taken instructions and just convert that into movement.
So the myth about three d printers is that three d printers have no idea they're
even in three d space that could care less.
All they do is get some instructions and move the motors and adjust heating and
a pulse things.
And that's it.
So you can't like throw a three d file out of three d printer printer and it
knows what to do,
um,
unless there's specific software to start to convert all that into movement.
Um,
so that's what they do.
and usually what we use is,
uh,
microcontrollers.
Um,
is anybody here like work on our Dino's any Arduino people?
Yeah.
Cool.
Um,
so in Arduino is a very,
it's an open source platform that you could program your own electronics and a
lot of these three d printers started in that way.
Um,
because,
uh,
the software was there,
somebody wrote these,
uh,
from wires that had all the,
the math and the algorithm and the settings,
uh,
to work with three d printers and then all these boards started coming up.
This is one of the boards we use a that's more sophisticated,
that runs the same way as the old type of boards,
but it's all more compact.
Um,
the cool thing about chips now is that they're getting better and better.
And now were you starting to use more?
Arm chips were really fast.
Like this,
a board is I think 16 megahertz.
Um,
and it's like a normal,
like 16 bit bored.
But now all the arm chips are like 64 bit or 32 in our like hundred megahertz.
So now they can handle all the crazy precision floating point numbers.
And all that stuff a lot easier.
And so like the delta,
Michigan's take more advantage of that because I have to.
Um,
but um,
this is like a,
a simple,
believe it or not,
it's a simple diagram of what a three d printer uses on these microcontrollers.
And you're all gonna get tested at the end of the day about this.
No,
I'm just kidding.
Um,
but as you can see it,
it's pretty,
uh,
pretty straight forward.
You have a bunch of chips that drive the motors,
so they're special chips that actually handle all the current that the motor
needs.
And all the chip has to do is tell it to pulse and in what direction and tell it
what direction should I go forward or backwards.
Um,
but you have these little things called drivers that are a little mini chips
that handle all the high current for the motors.
Um,
and then you have mohs fats which control your heaters and then their sensors
and a SD card reader and end stops.
And all these things are all controlled,
um,
by the microcontroller.
And,
um,
oh,
we're getting on time.
Um,
and then there's a,
a bunch of filaments.
So after that you need materials to print with,
right?
So these are some of the most,
uh,
popular materials and you guys could check them out either later.
Let me see.
Yeah,
we'll check them out later.
But there's a lot of cool materials out there.
Um,
and one of the newer ones that they're doing,
which is kind of cool cause a lot of people are like,
oh,
can't you print metal?
Um,
with this type of printer you really can't print metal cause you route to print
real metal,
you've got to melt it up thousand degrees or whatever.
But they're doing filament with like pla or abs that have like metal in it.
This is a,
a normal that I did on a Bukito that has iron in it so it can be magnetized.
So it's magnetic and it's like,
oh cool.
Oh that's something cool.
So basically what they do is they just grind up really fine,
fine,
fine metal powder,
and then mix that,
the good ratio with PLA.
Uh,
so it's not strong like metal,
but it could act or look like metal.
Um,
and then these are some of the materials that have to,
uh,
or the,
that are popular.
Pla is the most popular.
ABS is kind of getting the second popular,
but it's actually going to third.
And PETG is a new material that's coming up,
which is water bottle,
plastic type of material.
It's very strong.
It's a lot easier to print than ABS,
so you don't need a crazy heated bed to reach 110 degrees.
You only need it to about 80 degrees.
Um,
and then there's like flexible materials nylons and then the wood and metal
fills and you'll see samples of that here.
All right.
And um,
yeah,
so what's important about the filaments is that each one has like its
characteristics of how it likes to be printed.
Um,
so there's different types obviously,
but the settings are important.
The temperatures,
the speeds,
the platform surface is important.
Depends on what you're doing.
Some people are like,
oh,
I print pla and then they put abs and there and their falls off and it's not
working.
They're like,
why isn't it working?
Uh,
not all materials work the same.
And not all material stick to the same things or act the same way.
So that's something to look forward,
uh,
to understand.
And then there's the retraction thing.
Um,
each material has a certain way of liquid,
a liquid fighting through the nozzle.
And sometime when you want to move from point to point without extruding,
you've got to kind of suck in that material and move.
And that's where retraction comes in.
So if you see prince and you see all these little like fine little lines and
stuff,
either it was raining too hot or the retraction wasn't set right.
There we go.
Um,
so some of you guys,
uh,
already dealt with three d printing at some point.
Did you guys deal with the software end of it?
Uh,
as far as the slicing end of it,
by chance,
how many of you have worked with the slicer part of it?
I mean,
you guys know what slicer is.
Okay,
cool.
Well,
what the slicer is.
Um,
and what I did is I did a talk,
that's where these slides are from of a open source software because a lot of
the slicer software,
which is the software that grabs your 3-d file,
um,
and slices and creates code is a lot of it's open source and uh,
and it's pretty cool stuff.
Um,
so I talked about that,
give some market stuff.
Um,
but this is a quick workflow of uh,
of what,
how three d printers were,
right.
You start with the three d model.
I'm sorry,
it was a little fancier than it probably should be.
Um,
uh,
you place it into the software and the position,
um,
like where like how big you want it.
If you want more,
more than one,
you can fill up your whole platform with three d objects basically.
Um,
and then after that with the,
you set your settings up and then that creates what's called a g code.
Um,
and that's basically all the simple instructions of hey,
heat the temperature up to this,
move the,
the extruder from here to here with this much amount of volume.
And things like that.
Um,
and then after that you,
uh,
you get that,
that,
uh,
instructions,
that it generates and then you send it to the printer basically,
and either a USB form or a micro SD card in this case or another of wireless.
And some you could connect directly to your computer and run it that way.
Um,
so STL models,
anybody here write software or deal with three d software?
Three d space?
A little bit,
yeah.
Cool.
Um,
I don't know if you guys deal with STL files,
but STL files is like the lowest common denominator of three d printing,
I would call it.
Um,
it's basically when your object is just a bunch of triangles,
um,
to create your solid model,
that then the slicer uses to,
to figure out how to slice it up.
Um,
so it's Kinda a works,
uh,
an STL is basically a pure,
object made of triangles.
So there's no,
uh,
there's no curves,
there's no other instructions of how actually what the scale is.
The computer doesn't know what,
how big it is.
It's just a number is a number and a triangles,
a triangle.
Um,
that's how it usually STL.
So they're a little very,
very simplified.
Um,
so sometimes you might be in a,
the slicer software and you bring in your object and it was like super tiny.
You're like,
why is it so small?
And basically that means somebody exported it like into the inches realm.
Um,
so,
uh,
and then the software,
the slicing works in millimeters.
So I think so a one inch was one millimeter,
so it's like completely reduced or vice versa.
Sometimes if your software deals with inches and your models like enormous,
that means it dealt with millimeters instead.
Um,
so that's about STL files.
but you guys get this really fast because it's software based.
So let me,
uh,
move forward.
Um,
so
I mean,
let me actually run software.
Um,
so cure is one of the most of the more popular a softwares.
And I know Scott uses it.
Um,
so this is kind of what the software looks like.
It's pretty simple.
It has a bunch of settings.
Um,
what we do is we,
uh,
since it's open source,
we ha we say to our customer and go,
Hey,
here's the link for Kira,
download it.
And then we give them the set of what's called profiles,
which are all the settings for your machine.
Um,
so you kinda just go up and open your profile.
in this case we'll do a shortcut and we'll figure something out like pla and
that sets all these settings.
And uh,
in this software,
the first panel is basically all the,
most of the settings that you end up kind of changing dynamically according to
what part you're printing,
um,
like your layer resolution.
Um,
did you guys read that?
Okay.
It's kind of small,
but basically the first one is your layer heighth.
And what slicing software does basically it grabbed your three d model,
chops it up into whatever your layer heights you select until like flat two
dimensional pictures basically.
And then after that it grabs a,
it gets the rest of your settings.
Uh,
like how thick do you want your walls and how thick the top and bottoms are.
And it gets those two d slices and then it starts creating a tool path of where
the printer should be laying down material and how much material.
Um,
so if all your settings are our perfect,
you'll get objects like this.
Um,
the,
the thing about it is that if you're one of your settings are a little off,
your volume of extrusion can be completely,
completely wrong.
Um,
it gave a extruded weigh too much or not extreme enough.
so all these settings are pretty important to make sure they're a adjusted to
the machine you're using and the material you're using and everything.
Um,
so that's the software end of things.
Uh,
there's also advanced features obviously for fine tuning the speeds,
um,
the accelerations,
the temperatures,
all that stuff,
you could find tune the retracting,
uh,
like we talked about that you've got to retract every time it moves from end to
end.
Um,
yeah.
And then sometimes like in this one,
they actually have a different setting for just the first layer.
So if you have a printer that has like blue tape or something,
you want a little extra extrusion on that first layer,
it will do that cause you,
uh,
it's very important in three d printer that your foundation,
your first layer,
it comes out good.
Or else the risk of might not not be well,
you know,
if a,
if you build a house and they screw up your foundation cement,
your house might not stand up very well.
So it's kind of the same concept.
Um,
and then there's some cool software features that some,
some uh,
some of these softwares do and one of them is called a,
it's called a spiralize outer contour.
Um,
and this is a cool feature.
I came a while back and now they're,
they're making it really neat.
And what it is is a,
if you have a solid model that's solid everywhere and doesn't have any weird
spaces,
um,
what this setting or a feature does is that it will print you a nice solid base
first.
But then on the walls,
um,
if you could imagine the normal printing,
you print one layer and move up and print the next layer and then move up with
this spiral of feature does is it actually prints continuously as a spiral.
So every little segment it moves up a real tiny micron up on the z.
So it just creates an infinite kind of like spiral effect that gives you,
um,
I don't know if I have anything printed with it,
but it gives you a kind of like a vase cause you can only print the outside of
that with one thickness obviously.
Um,
but it gives you a very smooth looking basis with no seams and the resolution
looks a lot sharper to,
um,
it's a very interesting thing to do.
Um,
so basically mathematically they grab the,
the,
I guess the layers and then they split the segments of the layers into the layer
height itself.
So if you have a 0.3 millimeter layer and you have 500 segments,
you'd divide that by 500 segments and it makes food to do little by little.
Makes it cool little.
Uh,
and so your object comes out really neat and it's a continuous and actually
prince pretty fast.
Um,
so the,
the quick way to like use this software as you just get like a,
an STL,
uh,
you kind of loaded up
like that.
Now if it comes inside ways,
depends on your software,
you could always rotate it.
So it just kinda just kinda rotate it pretty easily.
Right?
Um,
and in this case,
this type of software slices,
you could see the corner up here,
it kind of slices really fast.
Um,
every time you change a setting and it starts to a slice again so you don't have
to wait for it or hit a button and then it tells you how long it would take and
everything.
Um,
and then you could actually preview what it would kind of look like with all
those paths,
those what's called tool path,
which is where the head moves and where it's going to move and where it's gonna
go faster and slower and all that.
So if you hit layers,
you'll see the effect of that.
Um,
my computer,
it's probably not too fast on this,
but actually this is a pretty big part.
But,
uh,
if you look down deep,
you could start seeing the features of this.
Oops.
Too much.
We're going to go or they haven't totally upside down.
Okay.
There we go.
All right.
I'm going to change to a smaller part because this is choking the processor.
Um,
let's do them all objects.
game of Thrones is a little too complex.
You could see one that's there.
Anybody Watch game of Thrones?
Yeah,
we had a little game of Thrones chair or they don't sit on it cause it's very
sharp.
Uh,
let's see.
Let's do something similar.
Bull Castle,
maybe it's all small one.
Cool.
So this is a castle,
I guess.
Very simple.
MMM.
Slicing.
And then you could see,
uh,
how the layers would look like.
And this is just a preview and it's kind of just outlining stuff.
Um,
now I actually,
I asked Scott about this,
but,
uh,
I guess Google is not working on any type of three d software that I know of or
anything.
But I think you guys should,
there's a lot of improvements we could use in this world,
in this realm of technology.
But,
uh,
as you can see,
um,
you could change slicing settings,
and you can actually see them happen,
which is kind of neat.
Um,
so if I,
so,
so in general,
this type of three d printing,
you don't want to print hundred percent solid objects,
right?
So there's the infill setting,
which creates like some kind of grid or a honeycomb.
Some softwares have different options for that.
And that kind of just fills in a lot of the gaps.
So your object strong,
but it's not 100% plastic and it uses up your whole roll of material.
Um,
so this is something you could like,
just change up like that.
Um,
and I'll re slice it,
um,
and then you'll see it happening.
Uh,
see what it looks like.
So according to your object,
like a,
this was probably a solid object when you got it.
Yeah.
So it's probably solid,
but in this case,
what he did is it just said,
hey,
don't put any in,
fill in it.
And so you get like a cup or a vase and then he'd say,
don't print the top party there and you could set all these settings and
sophomores.
Um,
cool.
Well there it is or as they unfold with the change that I made.
Um,
but I think since we're kind of at a time,
let's open it up for any questions and we could get into that if you guys like
you guys have any questions but
okay.
I know all you guys are doing important work,
so I don't want to hold you guys from their job,
but uh,
I'll be here as long as you guys need.
So do you guys have any questions that you guys might want to talk about here?
Yeah,
go ahead.
Yeah.
Okay.
That'd be cool.
Thanks for the talk.
Um,
so what true events your competitors from copying you from copying the machine?
Uh,
technically nothing.
Um,
I actually on this machine in my previous one,
I actually made him open source.
Um,
so I'm on this one.
I hesitated,
I didn't,
uh,
I call it open source.
I didn't root quite publish all the parts on it,
but if anybody asks me,
I willingly totally give it to him.
Um,
and mainly I did this to kind of slow down a little bit of people just copying
myself because unfortunately China actually made one just like mine.
I'm not as good obviously,
but,
uh,
they copied a lot of the same things and they made it super cheap and it's
unreliable and people complaining about it,
but that's the way it works.
Um,
but on these machines,
I did create the,
cause I started in open source,
the first machine I got,
it was a,
it's called Persia Mendel,
and it was all open source and I bought a kid and I built it.
And because of that,
I learned so much about how to build my machine that I felt like I wanted to,
you know,
pass the,
pay it forward basically.
So all my machines,
uh,
since this one I've opened,
the first machine,
I actually published all the files.
They're all on our wiki and they're all there.
Um,
on this one,
I published some things here and there,
but if anybody ever asked and they're like,
hey,
could I have your file of law?
I'm just,
I just give them the source files.
Uh,
nope,
no problem about that.
Um,
so fortunately,
no,
I,
there's nothing to stop people from doing it except the fact that open source
doesn't mean you could make money off of it,
but that's extremely,
very expensive to stop.
So it's not worth it.
Usually what I w I always like to,
my philosophy is always,
you know,
it,
let's innovate,
let's put out the products,
uh,
let's make money and to make more innovative products and keep ahead of the
curve as much as possible and just kinda keep going.
Um,
so that's kind of my philosophy of trying to work.
So cause people are going to copy it no matter what,
uh,
one way or another,
especially stuff that they could just buy off the shelf.
They'll measure it and make their own and that's it.
So there's not a lot of stuff you could patent on this.
Uh,
also,
which goes a few,
a little bit of the history is,
um,
uh,
three d printing was actually invented in the mid eighties.
Um,
and sometimes I start my talks like that and people are like,
Whoa,
where was it?
I go,
we know,
they know about it.
And what happened isn't it about,
about,
I think about eight,
nine years ago,
the main patents for this and some other one's expired because they were
patented around 84 and they made it as long as possible and to take about 25
years for them to expire.
And once they expired,
that's where the explosion happened.
Because those companies that had those patents never took advantage of like the
consumer level three d printing because they're like,
oh,
we're just going to make a hundred thousand dollar machines for,
for NASA and Jpl and,
and,
uh,
you know,
car company is,
they all use those,
uh,
the really super expensive one.
So unfortunately that's what kind of held this technology back.
I think.
Um,
the great thing is that right when they expired,
the Arduino was coming into light.
Um,
a bunch of software was coming.
It was a lot easier because of the internet,
all this stuff.
And that's what made this even feel the fire room or a with everybody making
their own version of three d printers.
Yes
though.
What?
Oh sorry.
Uh,
in regards to the patent,
yes,
I heard a rumor.
The curable one is actually starting to go.
Right.
Be careful.
Actually that was a first pen.
So that I think already expired.
Be a larger amount of smaller printers that can do that versus
there's already a bunch.
Yeah,
there's a lot.
The Sky made this hundred dollars version called the peachy brighter.
Um,
I absolutely don't recommend it unless he was just want to play with something
funny.
But he actually made this three d printer that's literally $100 or less.
Actually I should costs a lot less,
but he made it so you run it off an audio jack from your computer.
Uh,
I know it sounds weird,
but it's clever.
It's very clever.
And you can actually three d prints on me,
but you can't bring anything serious.
It was just so unaccurate I guess you might call it.
But basically it works with the,
with the mirror that with the audio.
Uh,
I guess,
uh,
I forgot how he did,
but what the audio,
he made the mere move in two dimensions.
Um,
and you shoot a laser that and your cure the resin and you put the resin in
water that salty and so as it cures and you drink more water,
it moves the liquid back up.
And it was,
it was very clever.
I got to give him that,
uh,
but not a recommended three d printer,
but now they have,
they have like thousand,
$2,000 printers that are resin based.
Um,
I have one that's about $3,400,
3000 bucks machine and that works with a projector and it projects underneath
where the resonance is and it pops it out of the liquid with a z access
basically.
Um,
so yeah,
that,
I think that was one of the first,
cause right after that one was patented,
they patent like this one like right after,
like they're like,
and then you had,
that's where three d systems comes from and that's where Stratasys comes from.
Three d systems had the SLA,
which is the liquid resin,
three d printer or pattens and then Stratasys,
how the FDM printers and they both kind of develop.
And then they started gobbling up companies trying to come up with other
patents.
Um,
and so they somehow,
the metal stuff somehow the powder ones and Ellie.
So,
but you know,
as soon as these patents start expiring,
like all of this competition starts coming up.
So you'll know when more patents expires.
Four sisters,
one patent that we,
uh,
one thing that we wanted to do a lot of people wanted to do is for abs printing.
We needed a heated chamber for a three d printer that had to be at like 80
degrees Celsius to print abs parts really well.
And they had a patent on it.
It's still,
I think it's still there or might have expired,
but nobody could make call their three d printer with a,
he need temperature control heating chamber or something.
It was like,
so like abstract,
like it was just like three d printer with heated chamber or something.
So it was like,
Eh,
how do you fight that?
Uh,
so yeah,
there's stuff like that happening.
So,
yeah.
cool.
Any other questions?
I hope no.
Anything.
Um,
I didn't talk much about the firmware I guess,
but,
um,
the firmware is pretty simple if you,
if you mess with Arduinos.
Um,
okay,
go ahead.
No,
no,
go ahead.
Go ahead.
So the firmware,
the ones,
the machines I have are,
I made our Arduino based,
which means you could use the Arduino ide to just hook up to the chip and
reprogram it to do whatever you want.
There's no lock on it.
Um,
you can't really read the data off of it.
You could capture it as a hex phone and save it.
They can't really reverse engineer it very easily the way it is compiled,
which I'm sure if you guys work with software,
you know what that entails.
Um,
but it's all open source.
So yeah.
What we did is we grabbed the open source software and we tweak the settings and
turned on and off features that we didn't won and won.
And we actually fixed a bug in it.
Oh yeah.
We could talk about it back in there.
That's a very serious buyer.
You too.
But uh,
yeah,
so we did all that.
That's all open source.
It's all available online and it's,
and it's always,
you know,
open sores.
It's just constantly changing and improving and getting more features and
different stuff.
So like now you can grab that same freedom from where we use like three,
four years ago and the new version now,
how's like the core x,
y features,
a delta features,
all that stuff is in there and you just turn them on and off as you need them
and then just reprogram your trip.
It's pretty simple.
Yeah.
Good question.
So the future where,
where do you see this going?
It's been around for eight to 10 years and it's,
Huh?
Well three prayer has been around since the mid 80 [inaudible] so it's like 30
years.
Right.
And it was to make the case.
So that's something useful so to speak,
is that when I'm going to be able to,
I don't know,
print a chair or something like,
oh well technically you could print a chair now you can print anything now.
It's a matter of if you,
if you could afford it or if it's actually practical,
uh,
that's where things are getting better.
Obviously things are,
you know,
it's always getting smaller or bigger,
faster,
cheaper.
That's always happening.
Um,
we're at that really good curve right now though,
that so many people are getting into it.
All these new ideas and new approaches are happening,
new discoveries are made that are getting this technology really moving forward
fast.
Um,
I can't say we're going to have the star Trek replicators yet,
or you just go up to and go,
hey,
I want a cup of coffee and then mixed the cup and pours.
It wasn't,
that's not there yet,
but we're getting there.
Uh,
and I think everybody's aiming for that.
Um,
but,
uh,
the diversity of three d printers,
it's like crazily diverse.
Um,
we have microscopic three d printers that they three d print microscopic things
to put into your body to either detect things or fix things.
And then you have three d printers.
I build buildings.
Um,
it just three D it's like this three d brain,
but lays down summit.
Uh,
if you could imagine that there's some really cool stuff.
If you look it up,
you'll find cool youtube videos about that.
This guy made like this castle in his back yard of cement with a three d right
now.
Huh.
Oh really?
Well that's one of the first days we started talking about cause we'd have like
people interview some things and there's a while.
Where do you think three prairie going?
And um,
that's where close to JPL was very inspiring to,
to have space programs next to us because we're in Pasadena.
But uh,
yeah,
we would say,
hey,
you know,
the ultimate three d printer would be to send one to Mars,
use its local resources and start building our house in foreigners.
Cause I already have my house designed for it.
But uh,
but I mean that's like the super ultimate type of three d printing,
which would be awesome.
The other thing is I think,
uh,
I mean I would like,
and I'm assuming three parents going to be like next to your microwave at some
point where,
hey,
I need this part because this thing broke off.
Dirtier,
dirtier.
It comes out,
you know,
it's going to be that easy.
And that,
uh,
you know,
that's simple and that diverse,
um,
the material science behind three d printing is like the,
probably the hardest part of it is how do you get certain materials to function
like you know,
production type of materials.
Um,
and you know,
if you make metal parts,
it should,
everybody expects it to be a part.
Like you machined it.
It's super strong super thing.
Um,
but there's also things you do that are discovered new with three d printing
that you couldn't do before,
especially in the space program.
I mean there's complex parts that are so light and so strong that has never been
accomplished before because of the algorithms you could use to figure out
exactly where to put supports in strengths and,
and holes and stuff to save material and all that.
Right.
Space X is three d printing rocket parts.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But it's not that they're not three printing because they can,
it's their three print cause they could add certain features to that that was
never done before.
Um,
I mean if you imagine things that have valves and channels and stuff,
um,
you could do that now without all in one solid part that before I'd have to be a
bunch of parts.
That means you have to add bolts and then you had unreliability.
Cause there's a big split there.
There's things connecting and stuff like that.
So now it's just like one part and it's like,
you know,
a third of the weight and twice as strong.
So there's a lot of stuff like that and they're developing more and more of that
too.
There's a,
one of the ultimate things I don't,
this sounds very impossible to accomplish,
but they might accomplish it.
Um,
you guys know the hyperloop,
you guys were,
you know,
it is right that train with the two.
So I have this friend that's,
uh,
he goes to crash base.
He used to work at space x and he's like a expert robotics,
robotic engineering stuff.
And,
uh,
last time I saw him,
he's like,
yeah,
I'm working on hyperloop and the higher,
and they're like,
do you want me to make this big machine that basically three d prints the tube
in place?
And I'm like,
what?
That's like mind blowing.
I mean,
imagine the materials,
like the cabling,
everything.
He's like,
yeah,
they just,
they needed to,
it has to,
uh,
build a tunnel and three d printed as it goes.
It's like there's stuff like that being developed.
So that's pretty intense.
It's pretty serious stuff and it all needs good software.
Um,
yeah,
but if anybody wants to ever,
if you,
I'm going to be open with you guys.
If you guys ever touch the software on three d printing and you want my
feedback,
like I'll give you serious feedback.
Uh,
um,
I'll tell you what I don't like and like,
and stuff like that.
And you have any questions about that?
I'm totally open to do that.
All right.
Cause I just want this to move forward.
So one day I will just three d print my body again,
you know how a new one,
so,
yeah.
All right.
So,
yeah.
Any more questions?
Anything else?
I hope that was cool.
Cool.
So please take me in a,
in a format.
Camera.
Speaker.
Thank you guys.